not bad
[Music]
everything you wanted
does it match up to what you
saw everything you need
everything you work so hard for
you might have your money but
go just can't
keep you warm through the stress
on the late nights
you pushed away what could
be yours
oh you deserve more
[Music]
and everything i wanted
everything that burns at my
core everything i needed
everything i stifle for decor
i don't have much money but
i have something worth
so much more a future
to grasp
if your hand will unclass
don't i deserve more
[Music]
and everything we wanted
i know it has changed from
before in our minds you
planted
a vision of a life we can't afford
we'll waste all our money on
what you have shown we'll mold it
as our own oh fill us
with floors
until we're over gorged
tell us we deserve more
[Music]
did you see his every moment
was it your choice you made
[Music]
judgment keeps us tame
to replace our dreams with
something far more monday
[Music]
we deserve
[Music]
we deserve more
[Music]
yep a fly went into my mouth
there is a spider on the guitar string